cyber security has many phases
and also many faces so you need people
that
are willing to read very long
documentation to understand how things
work
and to write some specifications to make
sure things work as they should
and take care of all edge cases
but you also need people that are let's
say
maybe less patient and just want to
receive
some black box or some product some
piece of code and just want to tear it
apart and to play with it
just like a child and to make it do
things that it was not supposed to
be doing welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
this one is all about low-level research
and the beauty of it
meet urite lanzette lead security
solutions architect at saimotive
lolita is originally a low-level
security researcher from 4-9 center in
she has been working in sai motive since
its earlier days as the diskin
advanced technologies and among her
roles in the company she served as a
penetration testing team leader
she is currently leading new
opportunities with automotive industry
clients from europe and the usa
and supporting the incubation of
innovative product ideas inside the
company
her passions include understanding how
things work and making them work
better she likes understanding motives
and seeing through the outer shell of
either people animals and businesses lit
lancet welcome to 20-minute leaders all
the way from the
simulative offices i'm guessing by your
background right
yeah you're right thank you i'm really
happy to be here thank you for joining
me
we have a lot to talk about we have a
lot to cover uh you know
from the the world of the deep world of
cyber security
and you know the really what's happening
there in the day to day and i and i'd
love to pick your brain and share a
little bit about what what is the cyber
security space for you
you know as a researcher and as an
engineer
and also going back a little bit to your
time you know in the army
and and the things that obviously you
you you can share
you were instructor and perhaps the most
uh elite and luxurious course for
computer scientists and researchers
in the in the israeli defense forces in
the cyber in the cyber industry
uh i'm excited to pick your brain on
that as well being an instructor there
that that's an amazing experience i can
only imagine
but wait walk me through a little bit
some of the big milestones
as you see them in your path and then
and then we'll dig deep into
some specific areas and we'll have a
good time
sure gladly um so i think
the first milestone um is always your
childhood
and how your parents approach you as a
person
and your education and what you're
capable and maybe incapable of doing
and for me this was a very big thing
because
i always felt that i can do anything i
want to i always felt that
i should work hard and i should learn
and i should excel
but they were very supportive of me
studying and
succeeding in the fields that are
interesting to me
um and also um i really appreciated my
father for being
um always the devil's advocate so if i
would come excited about a specific
topic and i would
say you know like any child i want to do
this forever and then he would say
hmm but what about the complete uh you
know opposite side
um maybe if we talk computer science
what about biology biology is
interesting maybe you should also look
at that
so i think this is a very interesting i
think parents are um really important on
this regard
um and i think i always uh felt
comfortable
with things that are let's say very
accessible
and that i felt that i can do from my
own home
um i was curious about understanding how
things work
and also for example i really liked
physics when i was in school
um and i really appreciated that things
having
some meaning maybe it's you know some
existential meaning
or um optimizational meaning or
something you can
do something with um so
i had an opportunity when i was in my
first high school year to go and study
um a degree in computer science at the
haifa university it was it is called the
it's gal program it is still running
today
yeah and yeah so you report
for context you're 14 years old right
right in your
and you're already starting your first
year in
university yeah and i think this was
great for me
um because it really opened my mind to
the the lengths at which you can gain
education and knowledge and
you know there were the internet and
computers there then but
it was a little more scarce than it is
today
for sure and it was an amazing
experience to be there with you know
older people and the the adults and to
study with them
um and to be given this opportunity and
to be treated like an adult
and so this was my first encounter with
computer science
and i really really loved it i loved the
setting i loved feeling like i loved
feeling like you know a grown-up person
um and i really enjoyed my studies in
the haifa university
and i think it gave me it gave me
better um fundamentals later on when i
um when i was let's say tested for my
military service
and i was back then in my studies i was
um really curious about you know the
actual low-level stuff
compilation processes and assembly and
everything like that and that led me
actually to to the course that i uh had
gone through and later on
guided as well um and during my military
service
um i also served as a security
researcher
um and performing binary analysis and so
on for sure
um for low-level devices let's say
and later on i had the opportunity to
um be a guide in the course and i was
really excited about that because
again i was curious about how does this
thing work
um who invented it and why how can we
change it to be better
how can i learn from it from my future
for the things that
work already and i think the combination
of um high technological
capacity with the um more
let's say psychological work and the the
empathy that you should have as a guide
really attracted me then um and it was
amazing amazing and just for context
because i think that
guide is you know i think that for
somebody who
doesn't experience this course it's it's
a it's a different mindset because
you're a commander
for for any purposes you're a commander
and you have
you know fellow soldiers that are just a
couple years younger than you they're
brilliant but they're a couple years
younger than you
and essentially you're working with them
to train them to be some of the best
researchers in the world
within a few months in a in a different
location that is not
their comfort zone not your comfort zone
and and so what was that like for you
having both that that commander
perspective at the same time
that intellectual curiosity that you're
there with them
working on some of the most interesting
problems that anybody in the world can
work on
yeah so so thank you for the
clarification um
for me it was an ongoing challenge
because these people
they know what they're doing so of
course you know the
each and every one of them lacked some
experience or knowledge in specific
topics but
you could always be standing up to a
challenge every day every hour of the
day
um it can be also you know just a
challenge that someone maybe broke a leg
because of some madas or
exercise during the course wow this is
also a challenge but
it is interesting because i was also
serving as
a teacher for assembly and also for
other topics and this was not the first
time
i was teaching i was also teaching i was
also prepping students for
their baguiot at the high school for
computer science but this is completely
different
so i think this challenge of how you
know
you cannot you can in my eyes you can
never be the most professional person
and know everything
but how do you approach this you know
sometimes
full of ego environment even if it's
from people younger than you that are in
a course
and how do you show them it's okay to to
be mistaken and you should ask
questions if you don't know something
and that technology says
means that you always learn something
new you can always learn something from
someone else
and you're going to make mistakes and
otherwise you're not going to study so
it was a lesson for me as well
elite how old are you when you're an
instructor in that course
um i believe 21 maybe
so a sophomore or junior in a
traditional
college in the united states and
because i think that the context of what
you're describing here
those personal experiences of both
leadership but also intellectual
curiosity and professionalism
they don't come to a lot of 21 a lot of
most 21 year olds don't
don't get to experience you know this
level of commitment and and resilience
and
you know i i remember i was an
instructor in in a course not as good as
alum
but i was i was also an instructor and i
remember
you work 22 hours a day on everything
and anything
and it's it's it's you know it's just an
unbelievable boot camp also
you know in in leadership and so i can
definitely relate to a lot of what
you're saying here
but you you finish the instruction in
this army phase and and now you're
inside motive
tell me a little bit about your personal
experience
with the cyber security world a lot of
things a lot of people
that don't really understand cyber
security they have these preconceived
notions of what it is
and it's sort of like a black box so
tell me a little bit about your
take on on what is cyber security and
why you're so excited by it
sure um so i think cyber security
um is exactly this combination of
understanding or aiming at understanding
how things
work and why and how they can work
better
or how can they be modified and used to
do things that they are not supposed to
do
um and this quest is never ending um
this definition shows it because you're
always on the run to
solve and solve a problem and then
someone finds a way another way
um to approach it so
i would say it should be a more um
holistic approach
um and cyber security is a never-ending
endeavor so
it's the means to understand
how my things are affecting my
uh business goals let's say for for a
company or how
my um code or my services
or even my product affects
other people or businesses around and
how
can they be modified and used against
what i am trying to do
and cyber security has many phases
and also many faces so you need people
that
are willing to read very long uh
documentation to understand how things
work
and to write some specifications to make
sure things work as they should
and take care of all edge cases
but you also need people that are let's
say
maybe less patient and just want to
receive
some black box or some product some
piece of code and just want to tear it
apart and to play with it just like a
child
and to make it do things that it was not
supposed to
be doing and i think in the past it was
more uh like this race
of you we have the attackers and they
are um
finding some exploits or trying to
attack some institutions
um or to break down a software product
or maybe a hardware product
and you want to you know put a patch on
that and solve it
and i think the world is now approaching
at a more holistic
uh way that it should be embedded in
your
overall development process and this is
i think what cyber security is all about
it's
it's exactly like um other business uh
processes that are an integral part of
your business it cannot be ignored
right and so when you no walk me through
a little bit about your day-to-day
so as a researcher what what what does
that even include
do you like do you know how the day is
going to look do you have
deadlines do you how does even research
take place
yeah so the deadlines is an interesting
point because there's always this
um conflict between just letting a
researcher do what i want what he wants
to do or what she wants to do
and between uh giving strict timelines
and so it really depends because some
research project can
be spread out along many many months
and for sure the mostly the more time
you have
you will find you will find more things
so it can be linear let's say
in in findings uh manner but
sometimes the ability to focus so for
example if i know i have a certain
program that i need to check for issues
um
and if i am sitting with maybe my
colleagues or maybe a manager
or maybe even just a friend from the
field
and i wanna try to understand what
scopes can i look at so what is the most
interesting part
um for me to test um is it more related
to
input validation or is it more related
um internal protocols inside the
the institution let's say or in the
internal network
um so this can also uh give you good
results
so there are a few approaches so one
approach is you just
you spray you try to attack ever to
attack everything that you can
maybe some fuzzing techniques you're
just uh reaching maybe the things that
you're more proficient at
so for example maybe i'm good at a side
channel attack so
it doesn't matter what this product is
about i love doing side channel attacks
and i will just go and do them first
um or it can be like we learn to perform
here um very organized so you have a
list of
all the possible roles
of the product or software all of its
inputs and outputs and you just need to
go one by one
and maybe sort these out to the relevant
skills that people have in the team
so for me let's say i would be a person
in a in a research team and i would be
um supposed to check a certain protocol
stack
so i can do it in a you know in the more
static analysis
way so again this is going uh function
by function or area by
area and um you know in a serial manner
or i can say okay i want to do it in the
more dynamic way
the program in a certain manner i want
to sniff the the network uh activity i
want to see what is really happening i
don't care about all the code
and i just want to go to this specific
code and try to attack it
so for example
right no no i think and i think that's
very very helpful
i can't believe tai moves so quickly in
such a cool conversation
so i want to address a you know a topic
that is really important to talk about
and that is
you know your role being a woman in the
cyber security field
we do see some you know we we see
things shifting and we see more women
involved and i don't know how many
how much improvement in the technical
scene but but regardless of the bigger
picture
i'd love to hear your personal
experience i can't imagine there being
many women with you in in the aram
course or or in in the cyber security
space today so actually
in my course we were three women so
it was it was impressive and uh it was
great to see that
um i will stay
out of home okay well we can live in the
middle romania um
and i will say that um this for sure
still needs improvement
i can say that i see a lot more women in
um development roles even very
you know the most technical and
mathematical and
um specific uh specific uh development
roles
i do see um less researchers
let's say uh security researchers but
for example now
uh we we are three women researchers in
in the company which is a lot for the
team
and i would like to see um the
environment or the people around
more supportive of uh of women and girls
wanting to do these things and yeah i
agree with that and i think but i think
that
more women um leaders and
technologics are speaking up for that
and
now you have more role models so it's
easier than
in the past
right and so what what do you think you
know in your perspective
what what is going to be the big shift
do you see there being some
something that can happen to make a big
shift do you see it more of a linear
slow
paradigm shift including the women in
researchers
environments so yeah
from what i see there's been passing a
lot of decades
with slow improvement in women included
in many sectors
and i think in israel it's sometimes a
little easier because we have the
military service and it can help to
shape
this and the lives of many girls um
and boys for sure but i think
that more emphasis should be put on the
earlier stages
so i believe in education and i believe
in
giving children even when their babies
like a few months the ability to choose
between a doll and the car the ability
to choose between
um talking with friends about computers
or talking with friends about
something else so i believe that this
should
i mean as long as we are not doing
something big in our early
earlier time education this is going to
continue be dripping
and not the mass that we need
right no that makes a lot of sense and
i'm already sorry that i called this
show 20 minute leaders
time passes by very very quickly and i
want to you know
take a side step from from this research
and
and it's emotive and what are you doing
there and go back a little bit back to
you
going back to your childhood what was
a topic that really fascinated you
perhaps in middle school
or you know right in the beginning of
high school or a passion
so i think in high school or in middle
school i
i was really um enthusiastic and happy
to start with physics
i studied in moffett class and you have
tasks to to get
um involved in this kind of classroom
before and i was really excited to start
the the pre-school
plan to learn physics i don't know why
it was
again it was understanding the life
around us um
but in a more uh technical manner let's
say
so i really liked physics during my
studies um
and i was really fascinated with the
computer science
um but not because i had a lot of let's
say experience in that
just from maybe my father had some
relevant experience let's say
very very cool and who would be a source
of inspiration for you as you go through
your personal impressions so i am
less of a you know some um someone
famous
as a role model i am not that much into
that
i like to find inspiration around me
so i can say nowadays um
one of the founders actually of say
motive um i really appreciate
um how he moves around the world how he
goes on
with his um let's say business
relationships and
he is he is also he was um
a professor at the university at the
states and i really like his unique way
to
approach business relationships and to
learn new topics and to view um
strategical
advancements in companies and also he
lives
everywhere in the world so he just
shifts between countries and he shares
this with his children
and i really appreciate his way of
living so he i think he combines well
uh the work uh and the you know
the fun in life and i really see him as
a role model
beautiful and what are some words
two three words that you would choose to
describe yourself with i would say
optimization for sure um
variety and and balance
beautiful thank you very very much
and thank you for the inspiration for
the time and stay
stay healthy thank you bye
bye